the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so let's go ahead and start lecture 6
which is all about strategy and we're
going to try to be numerical about it
because numbers make us feel smart so
strategy you know is a nebulous thing it
can't be easily defined and very many
people spend all day talking about it
without giving any statistics or
numerical results which i think is quite
ashamed because especially in this
battle code we can actually do
computations and say okay if I build
this many of X I can build this many of
Y and and we can get to some pretty
interesting results I'm going to start
out by just having a seat here and I'm
going to talk about some sort of general
stuff and then we'll move straight into
numerical strategy which I've got here
on the right of the view screen you can
see like I've implemented battlecode in
Mathematica to a limited extent for the
express purpose of showing graphs like
these so we'll get to the let's talk
about battlecode a little bit the way I
see it is that strategy can be expressed
as having a triangle aspect to it
because you're basically picking between
you know a technology route an econ
route and a military root and then among
military I like to try to draw another
line and you can sort of imagine this
triangle as being on a plane you know
this is on a plane that's like
perpendicular to this line indicating
that you can sort of be in any of them I
could have drawn it as a triangular
prism but I chose not to so so then this
triangles you know you can have like a
defensive military strategy or you can
have an offensive one offensive is
spelled that way and and you know I also
like to populate this map with even more
things to make it less clear what's
going on so I'm going to put over here a
large map and I'm going to put over down
here small map because if you're on a
small map you know you want to have more
military at least early on I mean this
is all time changing so you could
describe a strat
gee in time as being like okay first I'm
going to do a lot of military and then
I'm going to get some econ and then I'm
going to get tech so like that's a
strategy though it looks pretty weird
that looks pretty weird and it's
crossing out my small map anyway so
small map you know if you it is really
another way of saying like it's far to
the enemy base or it's close so on a
small map you can get right to the enemy
base you got to be prepared if they've
got a rush strategy it you know maybe
maybe what you ought to do instead of
saying okay I'm going to use the map
size is do sort of a heuristic because
you could imagine this map I'm going to
do example maps here and this map
currently identical now let's let's make
them different this one's got like tons
of Mines and this one has a little bit
of Mines obviously they're different I
mean if the headquarters are here and
here in these two maps well this one
isnt effectively a small map and this
one is effectively a large map so here's
a suggestion it's not very expensive to
sense mines at location it costs 10 in
the method costs txt file so you could
consider saying all right I'm this
headquarters for the first couple of
rounds I'm going to compute the sum of
the number of mines between me and the
enemy in sort of a volume looking like
that and so i'm going to i'm just going
to compute this number just going to
total it all up if the map is say 50 by
50 then how many tiles do you need to
count well say you make it four wide
just for the halibut and and then down
in this direction I guess it would end
up being sort of like 50 so you'd have
about 200 tiles to look at times 10
that's going to be 10 bytecodes per
cents tile and so you've only got two
thousand you can do that easily in one
turn because the bytecode limit is ten
thousand so then you could very quickly
get an estimate of how easy or difficult
it is to get to your enemy right off
there and so then you could find your
spot say okay I'm here or here on my
tech tree the system doesn't have to be
incredibly complicated
so let's let's delete some of some of
this mess that I made here so that I can
make some notes about the differences
between defensive and offensive strategy
later on we're going to see the number
of units that you can get at if you're
pushing for an early advantage and
that's going to sort of tie into this so
there's a time aspect where you're
saying if you're defending you have a
number of advantages one is that you can
have additional units up at the time
when the enemy arrives another is that
the padding is much easier because you
don't have to go anywhere you can
establish a better concave in theory
because the enemy might have to defuse
mines it's worth noting here that of
course you're not guaranteed this
advantage because the enemy knows where
you are you're sort of your sort of
around your headquarters I mean it's
it's generally true that if you can
recognize the enemy is around his
headquarters so he's all sort of clumped
up here well it's pretty easy for you to
say all right I'm gonna stay at a
distance R from that enemy and I'm just
going to sort of group up there and as
soon as everybody is within a distance R
and not farther than a distance this
other letter then then I know that I'm
in a good position to attack all at once
and so you know if the enemy is just
sort of hiding there in its hole then
that's that's also a vulnerability as
well as an advantage so you can imagine
that case and you could also imagine the
case where there's a ton of mines and so
the you know the minefield is like this
giant thick thing which is filled and so
you're defending over here and yeah
you're defending here and the enemy is
coming at you and they kind of have to
go in a line because it's such a big
minefield so you can just sort of
surround them yeah I meant to do that
outlining on purpose so so there oh my
goodness who can use Microsoft Paint I
certainly can let's see here so so yeah
you there's this concave ish
you and then there's another issue that
you can you can have the base take hits
so your you know your base has 500 hit
points so you can use that as a sort of
buffer to try to protect your robot it's
not a very good idea but but it would
spread out the damage a little bit so in
the event of an emergency it could be
superior to you know being farther from
your base also consider that it's easier
easier to heal your robots because
you're going to have this area sort of
established you're going to know where
things are you're going to have a safe
path to the nearest med bay that you
might build and later on we're going to
look at the effects of building med bays
versus other things it's going to be
really good so these are these are just
sort of a first look at things there's
some other stuff in here like about
tactical withdrawal you know when do you
realize that everything's gone to [ __ ]
and you've got to back out you know
what's the value of preserving your
units versus the penalty of having them
not in combat you know they're in
transit between wherever they are and
the medical Bay is that you've built
because you could you could easily
imagine filling the whole map with
medical Bay's just to reduce that
transit time and would that be worth it
compared to you know just not having
them go to bed base or only engaging in
battles within a certain range of the
Med base so you might actually be
retreating to a range rather than
directly to the thing itself these are
things that you'll probably end up
thinking about if you haven't already
let's let's jump straight into some
simulations so what I've done in this
model is let me zoom in just a little
bit is I've I've got a system where you
can build bots-bots-botswana ditional 10
resources per turn and the number the
the cost of building a generator
20 times the number of infants that are
currently built and here's plus one for
the additional one that you're building
same thing applies for suppliers that's
it's got the same build cost but instead
its advantages that the spawn time then
becomes this number note that this is
different from what it was in lecture 1
in lecture 1 the spawn time was ten it
was this it was 10 * point nine five to
the power of supplier number where
supplier numbers the number of suppliers
you have that's what it used to be but
it's been switched to this number in
order to make it slightly worse because
it was too good this and the other
changes have been updated on the battle
code data sheet that I made that you
might remember from the website so if
you're using that make sure that you've
updated recently and when you download
it hit f5 or refresh because it has the
same file name as before so your
computer might not download it again
unless you specifically tell it to
that's just something to worry about
because you know it's terrible to be on
a bad version of the specs because then
you think I'm wrong and that's just you
know very very hard to handle for me so
here's your here's your spawn time here
so that's what your suppliers are doing
for you and so I've made this model that
tries to build these things tries to
build robots and and it kills the excess
one so we're trying it we're trying to
reach a large number of robots the zoom
out just a little bit here so you can
see here that we've got power over time
and this is for 500 rounds I've got it
so that you can change the length of the
simulation and we're going to see quite
a number of simulations here today so
you can see here that at first you start
out with no power I don't know if this
is a hundred percent realistic because I
think in the game you might actually
start out with full power to begin with
but that's just so that's a transient
effect I wouldn't really worry about it
we're physicists here we're we're
talking about orders of magnitude yes so
so you can see here that initially your
power decays upward to some relatively
stable value but it begins to decrease
as you build robots because as the
number of robots increases over time the
upkeep is increasing and so your
decaying downward to stable values as
you go and then it becomes a able number
of robot
as they are produced and then they they
also run out of energy so I've also
plotted down here the maximum number of
robots that are achieved within the
simulation so this shows that you hit 40
robots at around 391 we're going to end
up looking at this quantity and trying
to see how we can make the most robots
at the shortest round number or how we
can have a trade-off between maybe
getting the most robots at an early
number or getting more robots at a later
number which would embody the difference
between a rush strategy and an econ
strategy I've also plotted the spawn
time so that you can see how the effect
of suppliers is changing how long it
takes for robots to spawn in this
example there aren't any suppliers so
the spawn time is flat so let's change
the example a little bit and zoom out
just a tiny bit making everything
illegible so that you can see also the
inputs to this function that I've made
and so I'm going to make it so that the
bytecode usage is 5000 and what effects
should that have it should decrease the
number of robots that we can sustain and
sure enough we see that when we run it
the maximum number we hit is now 27
robots around 261 so we've hit there
sooner but it's a smaller number it's
it's just it's just worse in every way
you want to save byte codes so let's go
back to that example now generator built
rounds and supplier built rounds is the
number of rounds between every time it
will attempt to build a generator or
supplier this is the basic version that
I started with so let's start by
building generators every 10 rounds this
is assuming that there are enough
generators around for us to build on so
you can see here that the first
generator is built around here there's a
tiny dip and here's another and another
but the generator doesn't actually kick
in and start to take effect until 50
turns later because there's a capture
delay and it doesn't do anything while
it's being captured then once these are
captured the number the amount of power
you have skyrockets so this was the
previous maximum at 200 and now we're up
to 2,000 power in just 500 rounds this
shows that you can really amplify your
economy rapidly you'll notice here that
the that the sawtooth behavior is
becoming increasingly severe this is
because each
one of these motions downward indicates
the purchase of yet another generator
which costs more than the last because
as I mentioned before the cost of
capturing an encampment is 20 times the
number of encampments you have already
so that's going to linearly increase you
can see that it's recovering faster and
faster though because as has been
mentioned then um the generators do
produce ten energy per turn so here we
can see that it's not hitting any limit
to the number of robots that can be
built and if we extend the simulation
out to two thousand rounds we can see
that it just continues on as it was
before and the number of robots is
unlimited so if you do find a map that
has a whole lot of encampments to
capture and we haven't specified that
there's a maximum number of encampments
as far as I know then you could end up
just continuing to build these things
and then it doesn't matter how terrible
your micro is or how terrible your tech
is because you'll just out you're just
overwhelmed overwhelmed the enemy Hey
look at around 1991 what a good what a
good year that's that's pretty special
so let's let's go back down to 500 where
we can see what's going on and let's
change generator built rounds to 1 so
now we're going to try to build a
generator every round but look at here
these red dots indicating the completion
of generators are non uniformly spaced
that seems to indicate that it's not
able to build generators every turn
that's because there's not enough power
you can see here that the power is as
close to zero as it possibly can without
destroying robots from bringing it down
to negative values so you can see here
that you can now get to have more robots
than you otherwise would have no that's
not true you can't have any more robots
because we're still limited by the rate
at which they're being produced they're
only being produced one every 10 rounds
and that's that's really cramping our
style as it were so let's increase this
back up to a million so that it's not
building any more generators let's try
building just suppliers so let's build a
supplier every 10 rounds as you can see
here here's the money being expended on
suppliers and pretty soon even before
round 100 we start hitting a point where
the number of robots we have which is
accelerating over time as the spawn time
is decreasing the number of robots going
up is preventing us from getting enough
power to
new building suppliers so we're actually
capped this this behavior where the
power goes down and crashes is going to
really hurt our our ability to play the
game it becomes exacerbated the faster
you build suppliers because you see here
I've built these suppliers and then
bingo you know I've only built a total
of let's see here supply your number
I've built a total of eight suppliers
within the first I don't know this looks
like 40 turns and now I'm not going to
be able to build anything else for the
whole game because the next encampment
that I by would cost eight times 20 is
160 plus 20 for the next one is going to
be 180 I can't I simply can't afford
that if my power is never exceeding 170
over here so that's pretty much going to
be a crippling blow so maybe as my
player I need to do one of two things
one maybe I should build suppliers and
generators to I could notice that maybe
the enemy has killed a bunch of my
generators but i still have suppliers
left over have you thought about that
maybe some of your suppliers will have
to destroy themselves to make room for
more power generation it could be
something that happens to you less than
not ever or which is to say more often
than not ever so let's make it 10 and 10
so we're trying to do some of each well
it's not really working it's like
building some and then the others
because one of them is taking precedence
over the first maybe we'll try building
these every 20 and these every 10 well
now it's building some of each this is
not so bad so now we're getting 276
robots at 496 our power is going up but
we're not so much wasting it as we were
before and we can see that the spawn
time has gone all the way down to half
now this does assume that none of your
robots are being destroyed if you're
actively losing robots it makes perfect
sense to build only suppliers because at
that point you can clump up your units
and lose them which will give you the
money to continue building units it's
only when you've favored suppliers and
then not attack that you're wasting your
effort and time so this is something
that I saw in some of the scrimmage
manages that I've been looking at
because we devs have access to all kinds
of secret information about you
including the performance of your
players in scrimmage matches so I've
been downloading these maps and looking
at them and in these matches I've tended
to see that a lot of times we're
favoring suppliers but not attacking
other times we're favoring suppliers and
we're just sending our units one by one
to be killed by the enemy blob I think
that's also suboptimal but at the same
time we have seen quite a few good
strategies I've seen some great padding
and I've seen some great solving for the
map I think that there's a lot to be
done there and I have confidence that
we're going to see a lot of great
matches in the sprint tournament so
let's go back to the model here and look
again at may be getting a build order so
here the build order i'm defining as
what order do you get suppliers and
generators this way of doing it as you
see as you see i've implemented it here
is kind of inefficient because whichever
one goes first is just whichever one you
know hit the round counter or something
so here I reimplement the whole system
with an explicit build order so i can
say all right please give me a bunch of
two and then give me two and then one in
alternating turns so you can see here
that it's not working very well two is
my indicate is my number for the
supplier and one is my indicator for the
generator so here we do five tues and
then we alternate two and one forever so
there are the 5 2's and then we've got a
2-1 and a-two and a-one well that's not
very good because we still crash and we
only hit a maximum of 57 robots so let's
consider reducing this number of two's
well that's much better so now we've
gotten up to 87 robots around 495 now if
you've been keeping track in your mind
of which number of robots we've hit it
which round congratulations you're much
better at that than me later on I'm
going to be showing plots so that we
don't have to memorize how many robots
we have at what round but for the sake
of illustration it's pretty useful to be
able to say all right if I add one more
supplier here how does that help me well
if you look very carefully it's going to
shift your early number of robots up and
it's probably going to shift your late
number of robots down that's the way
it's changing the shape so you can see
here that that's a very subtle change
let's change it so that we're only
building suppliers and then we're only
building generators so there we've built
a few suppliers and then a lot of
generators that's 62 robots we can keep
changing it and try here's a few more
suppliers well look at that we never got
the chance to build any generators
because we ran out of energy when we
were building suppliers this is the same
issue that we were seeing before so
let's explore the space automatically
this is kind of weird what I'm going to
show you is a plot of the peak number of
robots that you've gotten during the
simulation versus the number of rounds
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
sort of move along the space in some
line which is going to be an automatic
search for these various things we're
looking for so yeah so where do you want
to be on this graph you want to be up
here at the upper left because that
means that you're getting a lot of
robots at a small number of rounds this
is the phenomenon that we were seeing
before we're going from 1 2 3 5 7 8 you
can see that it's skipping some numbers
because they would have written over one
another so I've yeah let's say I'll show
I'll show it with all the numbers well
that's odd change shape ah but up up up
up up well let's go with it so this
example is ah did I did I define the
explicit system this is the explicit
system here did I set that and then did
I define it well alright that's how it
is so so this is the system is showing
you from 0 up to 15 for every time it's
trying a longer or a shorter system of
building the suppliers so if it says
zero it means it just goes straight into
generators and if it says a higher
number then it has built that many
suppliers before it goes into generators
so you can you can see ya so that that's
there and the numbers sort of start to
overlap one another so i made this
little function that gets rid of the
numbers if they're too close to another
number and that changed the way it
looked quite a bit
take that load up i see i see it was
going out 2,000 thank you thank you so
let's make this yeah let's make this
just a 1000 strategy exploration is
there simplified exploration is here
yeah so there are the numbers and this
at this phenomenon is the thing that
we've been seeing before that as you
have more and more suppliers to begin
with you can it's okay up to a point at
which you can't build any more robots
and you hit a limit because you've run
out of power okay that's what we've seen
seen in a hundred ways that's good let's
switch to a mix of things so instead of
doing all one we we do a mix so that we
were alternating one and the other so in
this example we're we're starting with I
numbers of suppliers and then we're
going to follow it up with alternating
generators and suppliers you can see
here that the best result seems to be
something I mean you really can't decide
just based on this graph because you're
these are these are maximum points and
could you know is this is eight is that
a better way to operate for a rush
strategy well here's a way of addressing
that question here I've plotted the
number of robots versus the round for
this zero and you can see here that it's
always above the other peak robot counts
so that indicates that it's definitively
better to start building generators
before you start building suppliers at
least if you're aiming for the peak
robot condition you're trying to get the
greatest number of robots so there you
go it's the better it's better always to
use 0 and here if we compare different
strategies we can see them on the same
space and one it's obviously better this
one above here that that's new is much
better than one we had before it gets us
more robots at the same round number and
again we're trying to get to the upper
left of this graph this strategy
consists of building a generator and
then building a supplier I times so
we'll do that set I times and then we'll
go into building 122 so then we'll be
building a generator for every two
suppliers and we can see that this is
much better at any point so that's
that's pretty interesting
that is that is pretty interesting
because then we can say all right I've
played around with this you know maybe
maybe it's better to have three is that
even better we'll see we'll see that
changes the shape a little bit so that
gives me a bit of an improvement in this
region so if we really want to have the
most robots at this round possibly the
best way to do it is to start here I
know that these are all pretty obscure
looking so I'm going to just skip
straight on down to over here where we
can look at the effect of a rush and we
can see it very concretely that in this
example we've got the first guy in blue
he's building only generators and 440
440 rounds and then he's going to start
building suppliers so there you can see
blue is building only generators and
then he starts building suppliers and
his robot production rate increases here
in red the red guy is starting by
building suppliers and so you can see he
caps out at 41 suppliers so he can't
he's got or 41 robots for a moment and
then he's back to oscillating so he's
got a military advantage in this window
starting from around 100 going up to
Round three hundred where for a time
he's going to outnumber the enemy and
his goal is to win during this time so
if you outnumber the enemy starting at
round 100 and going to 300 here's what
you have to do you have to get to the
enemy and start shooting at it so if
that's a if the map is really really big
like if the map is a hundred size 100
you don't have the pickaxe upgrade so
you're going to be defusing mines at
twelve rounds per turn of twelve rounds
per mine if you've got 50 mines in the
way and 12 each there's no way that
you're going to get there because it's
going to take you five hundred rounds
just to get to the enemy and you'll
never actually start get to start
shooting but if you can find a straight
path to your enemy even if the map is 50
units long you can get there and start
capitalizing on your unit advantage
before his econ play kicks in so there
you go a very concrete example of the
effects of rushing or playing econ at
the same time you could definitely
imagine intermediate strategies so here
I'm just going to go ahead and plot a
third strategy which maybe I'll make in
green
and maybe this strategy is a mix of the
two so instead of starting with just
generators or just suppliers will do a
combination of generators and suppliers
now look at that that's pretty
interesting let's extend the simulation
length to 800 rounds and we'll be able
to see the effects so now we see that
the green player does almost as well as
the red player it's almost
indistinguishable at this distance and
given the defensive advantage we talked
about earlier it may be enough for the
green player to hold off he'll still be
able to smash the red player and he
still got an advantage over the blue
player without being that much at a
disadvantage that is to say that the
green advantage last until about round
six hundred let's zoom in a little bit
so that we can see round six hundred and
try to assess how much better the green
player is than the blue player so here
once again green is building alternating
generators and suppliers and he has an
advantage over blue starting at about
round 100 and going to about round 450
that's a pretty big round that's a
pretty big advantage for a pretty long
time it's only at that time that blue
begins to take off and gets a serious
advantage so you can see here that
there's a pretty significant difference
between different strategies and that
you can achieve a significant difference
of units but how many differences of
units are important to start really
making a difference I mean if you have
ten units versus their 11 how good is
that is that is that a lot is it a
little it doesn't seem like very much
well to answer that question I've made
yet another simulation because you know
why not do a simulation simulations are
fun so here's a here's a look at it and
what I've made here is sort of a very
basic simulator that works in the
following way I'm going to zoom in a
little bit so this is some combat and
I'm going to simulate the combat between
10 and 11 units I'm going to do it a
couple of times I'll start out doing it
slowly with a with a decrease in the
compute time here so there's 10 there's
11 units on the bottom and these are
their hit points and there are 10 units
on the top so you can see I'm going to
do it once again this is I'm going to
start with 10 and 10 this is team a on
top and team be on bottom and you can
see here that when there are the same
number
units they all lose head points at the
same rate and they all died at the same
time at least in my simulation when
there's an advantage that extra robot
that you have can start dealing
additional damage to his robots and so
that advantage becomes more significant
over time so if we have a hundred units
versus 101 units you know then we'll be
here all day but the point is that
you'll end up seeing as more and more
significant difference between the two
that didn't seem to work quite right did
it but you know perhaps it did it may
just have the exact same result I'd be
quite curious well in any case we're
going to go back to the example we were
showing before what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say ok when you have 10
verses 11 the 11 team ends up with four
units left and two of them are very low
hitpoints but two of them have a lot of
hit points remaining so we can start to
define two quantities the robot kill
ratio and they and the HP kill ratio so
the robot kill ratio is to say i put in
11 units and I got out four of mine
remaining so 11 is the bottom I got four
remaining so that cost me seven but in
the process of costing me seven I was
able to take out 10 enemy units so
that's 10 / 7 and if we make it
numerical with a decimal point there we
see that number question so I'm actually
modeling the combat by distributing the
attack evenly from one side and the
other and then any remaining units will
have the opportunity to deal more damage
to the to the enemy team so I don't know
exactly how accurate it is and if you
can manage to maintain a tight choke
point then you can trade evenly with
your enemy but that's the best you can
do if you're outnumbered if you're if
you have the advantage you know and you
surround the enemy then you could do
even better than this this is something
like a middle ground between those two
cases good question if you want to see
the actual way that it works learn
Mathematica and read the code that's
right here so we see here that there's a
robot kill ratio that's pretty good we
Came we came to the fight with ten
percent additional units and we ended up
getting forty percent more value out of
our units that we lost
on on a hit point basis we didn't get
that much of an advantage bringing a ten
percent advantage got us six percent hit
point advantage on on how many hit
points we were able to lose versus the
enemy so let's look at a lot of results
so you're on the left I've made a table
so I've just done the simulation for 20
units versus AI units where I goes from
21 to 30 so we can see the force ratio
that I'm bringing to the table here I'm
exact here I'm imagining that I have
more than the enemy but of course you
can just invert these numbers and get
the reverse case the forest ratio I'm
bringing is five percent extra ten
percent extra and so on and that
achieves these unit kill ratios you can
see here I've capped it out at 20,000 so
that it doesn't display the infinity
sign because here once you have more
than 30 once you have more than one
third more than the enemy you don't lose
any units at all during combat that's
according to the simulation that I've
set up a pretty amazing result if you
ask me so you can see here that the unit
kill ratio magnifies quite intensely the
hit point kill ratio doesn't magnify
that intensely so here five percent
force ratio gets you about twenty
percent unit kill ten percent gets you
forty percent fifteen percent gets you
eighty percent extra and then once you
get up higher it just wraps up more from
there so shows that even if you're only
even if it's a fight of five verses for
you probably it's probably a very bad
idea to engage the enemy because you're
not going to be able to kill any of
their units before they kill all of
yours which means that all there's can
sort of head back to a med bay get
healed up and then be back to the fight
it's worth mentioning here that you know
the men Bay can end up being as
productive as your headquarters so let's
zoom let's go back up to where I've
talked about the medbay let's talk about
it here so let's talk about the
production abilities of your various
capability you've got you've got your
your headquarters which is making units
at 40 hit points each and let's say that
it produces them every town rounds or
maybe every five rounds at best if
you've got a lot of suppliers so this is
your headquarters building units so it's
building hit points every turn so it's
building from four to eight hit points
per turn
that's not too bad that's building for
28 hit points per turn but what about
everything else a med bay can heal to
head points for every 8 for every of the
adjacent units so that they're right
there is if you can multiply correctly
it's 16 hip points per turn that's so
many that's the value of to headquarters
right there as even considering
headquarters at full supplier capacity
that just shows that even if you're
using med bays incorrectly or doing it
wrong in the various ways that you can
you'll still be doing a much better job
than a headquarters alone I mean that's
ignoring the fact that there are other
things at play here but like you have to
have injured units in order to produce
hit points at a med bay but it's
certainly worth mentioning that even
this basic analysis shows what it is
very clear now what's the killing
ability of artillery it's been said that
they're overpowered or that they're
quite strong and they're definitely
worth using but is the killing power of
an artillery worth it compared to the
healing power of a med bay purely from a
numerical standpoint you can see here
that the best the artillery can do is to
deal 40 damage to its target in 20
damage to each of eight targets adjacent
for a total of two hundred if I did that
math correctly and that it does that
every 20 turns which is its attack delay
so that gives us 10 hit points per turn
look at that often times 10 less than 16
true true it's even going to tell me
that well what a big surprise so you
know you can make the decision for
yourself and if so and of course each
one has its own uses because the you
know that artillery is not always going
to be able to deal 10 hit points med bay
is not always going to be able to heal
units maybe it's too far from the
headquarters to be a real defensive
asset maybe not there are a lot of
considerations to include but doing a
calculation like this can certainly help
you out in making your decisions for
example i mean i think it's worth doing
the following check check if there's an
encampment near your base if there is go
ahead and make it a midday if it's not
that near maybe it's better to make it
artillery like if it's if it's adjacent
you probably want a med bay but if it's
not close the med bay becomes less and
less valuable whereas if it's in still
artillery range you know maybe it's
still worth having it's you know it's
the kind of question is kind of
trade-off you could make
just hard coded in you know if it's more
than a distance 16 distance squared 16
then go ahead do it this way otherwise
do it that way you know very simple way
of addressing the problem so let's go
back down and let's talk more about
Encounters of units so let's continue
with this with this unit kill ratio
results table so we're here and and you
know it's kind of hard to look at
numbers oftentimes when people have a
lot of numbers especially at a table
they plot it so here I've got a plot
doesn't mean that much let's do let's do
a list plot so we've got points and so
we're asking the question you know here
is the input is that the input know the
input is a goes up to 1.2 yeah the input
is here so this is having the same this
is having five percent advantage ten
percent advantage and so on and you know
the question is how many you know how
many hit points is that worth for you
what hit point advantage does that get
you and so we could do you know a best
fit for this for these results so in
Mathematica that would look like find a
fit you put the data in you put you put
the expression ax plus B where a and B
are the parameters and X is the variable
in question and this is this is your fit
rule and then you can just apply that to
the expression and in one line we can
have another and then we'll have another
will have a plot so we'll plot this
thing mess that it is well okay why
don't we just call it here the line is
this so we're finding the best fit line
here and we're going from X goes from I
don't know 0 2 1.5 and that ought to do
it for us we'll plot that line and we'll
plot these points so called points
equals that and we'll show the line
together with the points and we'll also
be able to show other things plot style
red will make the line read because
that's real style that's real style that
almost worked there you go so there's a
line what you know what line is that
it's the line where
the line please tell me the line it's a
it's point six nine so there you go the
slope here is point six nine so that I
mean of course this is probably not
valid down at these low numbers but the
point is that for every additional one
percent or you know one unit that you
add that's going to be an extra 70 extra
point seven units that you're going to
damage of your enemy and you know it's
sort of fairly linear between one and
one and five let's see if we really
dominate the enemy how the results will
sort of stack up so here it's simulating
a whole bunch of combat it's going
really slowly why is it going slowly boo
because I put in like that delay thing
so that you could see what was going on
so I'm going to change the delay 20 they
scroll right on back down giving
everybody in the room nausea I there's
also a bunch of print statements so
we're seeing like 200 print statements
which was to print the dynamic results
of the match so you could see them
fighting you know sort of seeing numbers
decrease on a board which is a lot like
combat in the eyes of a nerd so then we
can see here a bunch of force ratios and
here in this example we see that we're
maxing out at a certain number so
according the way that I've set set up
this simulation beyond a force ratio of
two you're not getting any additional
advantage out of your additional troops
because they just can't find a place to
stand in reality when you have four
versus one or eight verses one there's a
place for all of your eight guys to
stand around all of their one poor
little guy but if you have a large
number of units it may be less realistic
to assume that there's that much room
available for them to double team or
quadruple team or a purple team the
enemy so you can see here that these are
some results and now if we plot them
again we see that we sort of hit this
ceiling right over here and so the line
you know sort of is totally destroyed
and comes out wrong if we go let's go up
to let's go up to three so we see how
badly bad-looking it is and this is just
yet another example of how you know
doing a doing a best fit line to
something is not the right answer a
hundred percent of the time it's it's
the right answer ninety-nine point nine
nine percent of the time or basically
use the r-squared number to see if it's
no I'm just kidding that's not that's
not genuine statistics and most of you
are probably pooh-poohing the idea that
I even considered for for a moment or a
nanosecond including the two words in
the same sentence
so that's a sort of summary of these
issues like you know what force ratio
gets you what unit or hit point kill
ratio you can see here a big takeaway
lesson that just twenty five percent
more units or just thirty percent more
units in the enemy can make a giant
difference and you should never engage
when you're outnumbered unless you're
right next to the headquarters and
there's no choice I strongly recommend
that you consider a little micro tricks
you know trying to get your units into
the right place withdrawing when it's a
good idea remember that if you're
retreating from the enemy and the enemy
is adjacent to you that means you can
take damage every turn while you're
retreating so you know in this game
retreating is definitely not encouraged
for that reason what you need is like
allied units to sort of distract the
enemy while you're injured ones are
going to heal or you need to have your
med bay is close enough that you can
survive the retreat because the way the
way the game works is you move and then
you deal attack damage so if you retreat
from your enemy you're not adjacent to
him anymore after you've moved and then
he moves toward you and deals damage and
then you retreat and you don't do damage
and he moves toward you in deals damage
and it's just a very bad situation I've
been in it myself it was very painful to
watch so with that I mean I I think I
think that's got that's going to be all
that I've got for you today even though
it's slightly early other days I've gone
over and so I recommend that you just
sort of sit here enjoy yourselves ask me
questions and when the bubble tea
arrives the deputies will spring into
action so thank you very much for coming
to lecture six I guess I guess I should
explain what's going on in the next
lectures next lecture is going to be an
exciting guest lecture where we've got
one of the developers of battle code
who's been remote and who was the winner
of battle code last year fun gamers on
that team he can't he's coming here to
talk about various important things I
forgot what he's talking oh my goodness
what a terrible what a terrible plug for
his for his talk it was going to be
about no that wasn't a helpful comment
that was just talking yeah he's going to
talk about I think emergent complexity
and like really awesomely tricks that
you learn if you do battle code in years
where n is a lot
number